hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for today's video
we're going to be talking about uh
something interesting that's taking
place in the hog market right now um you
know people say Hogs what the hell why
are you talking about this Market
because the market hit limit down and
you know I think it's an interesting
topic to talk about because it's not
something you're going to see in other
markets right um not all markets have
daily price limits you know a lot of the
uh stock indices they they have uh
circuit breakers but you know when a
market hits limit down
it's you know it's interesting okay so
that's why I want to talk about it but
before I jump in you know remember if
you're enjoying my videos be sure to
subscribe to the channel click the
notification Bell so you don't miss any
new uploads and if you find today's
video helpful be sure to hit that like
button for me and leave a comment um
sharing your biggest takeaway you know I
love hearing your feedback and your
support really does go a long way in um
you know giving me the motivation and
encouragement to make more videos all
right so let's get started with today's
topic all right so um
Hogs h e right is the symbol people say
why you want to talk about Hogs well you
know there are some traders that you do
use orderflow my software specifically
to trade the agricultural markets right
they I know they trade the grains and
there's a few that actually trade the
Hogs okay but today we sort of got into
a special situation um when the market
hit limit down right what does limit
down look like it looks like this right
you don't see any anything trading on
the bid um you'd have to look at a dome
right to see what the sizes of what is
called the pool right the limit offer so
you can see 71 SP
77 is 1519 contracts so there's
1,519 contracts trying to be sold at
limit offer now people say well I see a
bid here 172 at 71 spot 75 yeah but you
cannot trade it the daily price limit
the most that the market could move move
in
Hogs is
3.75 which is just about 5% Okay so
yesterday go back right yesterday we
closed up here at uh
75 about 47 and today we opened up at
7355 and our daily limit is down there
at
7177 right which is just
uh what's going on here right down
here right
7177 right here right this is our daily
limit
so you know we open up we're already
down about you know 2% get down to about
3% and this is where knowing if you're
trading this Market or um certain
markets now if you want to know what
markets have daily price limits just go
look on the uh CME website okay see
website lot of information so if you're
trading you know some of the
grains you know it's good to know which
markets you know what their daily price
limit is and you can see here lean Hogs
it's
0.037 you know there's a five there but
you know Traders don't really talk about
that five because it's you just deal
with that cut it off there at seven but
um you know cattle also okay if you were
to look at the contract specs here
okay so you know a few years ago you
know they changed it to a a financially
you know the contract they sort of
changed it a bit made it financially
settled as opposed to um physically
delivered
but if they have it here on what it says
where their daily limit is here no I'm
surprised you used to have it also on
the contract specs but you can see here
like you know here price limits okay so
it just takes you to that page okay but
again you don't see things like equity
and indices on here or currencies um
they don't have those daily limits that
you have you know these are hard limits
right so once it hits that limit you
know like if it was
um you know soybean meal 30 bucks if
once it moves there it can't trade
beyond that level okay and you know it's
important to note that you know when a
market hits Limit Up limit down
obviously there's going to be a usually
you know the next day it will continue
now when Traders you know they they they
think that the market
closes when it hits limit down it's not
right what you have is it's hit limit
offer in this case you I say limit down
you know it's basically limit offer it's
offered out at this price right now
there's almost 2,000 contracts there you
see um earlier it was like 1500 1600 now
it's up to, 1900 we're coming into the
close soon but you just can't sell below
this level so if you want it to sell you
have two choices one join the offer at
limit down someone comes in buys clears
out everything in front of you you can
get filled okay chances of that
happening late in the day probably not
that high because there was a few
moments here right we hit that limit
down right here bounced up a little bit
a couple minutes later um then about uh
you know about 15 minutes later did get
a little bounce here but that was it it
was just then it was just everyone
coming in joining the offer joining the
offer joining the offer okay but the
market is still open for trading it's
not closed as some people would have you
believe um you just can't sell anything
you can buy all you want okay and then
you
know this is this triggered me a while
back over the summer I was just driving
in my car randomly listening to some
YouTube videos and and someone had
talking about the market being limit
down and you know looking at the order
flow you can't see any buying or or
selling you know it's useless well yeah
the Market's limit down all you have is
selling pressure
right I mean all this is this is just
insane selling pressure that's what why
the market is limit down there's 1,00
contracts on the offer here okay and
they say well you can't see any buying
pressure well no nobody wants to
buy it when it's limit down you know
there is some trading going on here I
mean you see one two I don't know what
that is you know maybe it's just
somebody that was short from earlier you
know maybe they want to just you know
say I'll just cover it here now you know
go go into the weekend flat or spreads
because you can see here right there is
limits on
spreads you can trade calendar spreads
so you can do you know for example you
this is the December Hogs right you can
see there's all these listed contracts
right there's Feb April May June July
August o October December maybe you do a
a calendar spread um you know D D
calendar spread or D June or D Feb or
something because you know there are
markets out there right those spreads
have wider
um daily limits so you know you can
still do a spread and oftentimes that's
what um grain Traders will do right if
if in the grains right they hit limit
down or obviously they can go to the
cash mark market and participa in the
cash Market cuz you know when when
grains in the past would hit limit down
you know a lot of traders that just go
to the physical Market okay and and and
trade that way so and you know that's
how Traders would understand you know
where are we going to be tomorrow is by
where you know if Market is limit down
here you know saying you know asking
their their farmer friends where's the
cash Market on on Hogs right now well
let say it's about 70 bucks okay so yeah
we still probably got a capacity for
this Market to go lower now you and I we
don't have farmer friends that we can
call up and and get that information
from but you know the guys that trade
these this market for a living they do
have those people they could call up but
again you know the markets with daily um
limits right it's kind of limited no pun
intended but again you
know
soybeans bean oil meal CR uh well Crush
but that Trad separately as a soybean
Crush bread um soybeans against oil and
meal rice um Oats not you know hardly
anybody trades that cattle Kansas City
Wheat um Chicago wheat as well it's got
daily
limits um butter and cheese but you know
it it's not just but if you're trading
you know some of these Commodities do
understand that there's price limits and
if you see the market you know if you
come in to the TR trading
day I mean obviously if if you're
specializing in these markets you know
you you should know where the daily
limits are but if you're coming into the
day and you you just see the market down
so much you got to understand where's
the limit because worst thing you want
to be doing right if you're unaware that
the daily price limit is down here and
you're thinking you know for whatever
reason oh my gosh you know maybe I
should be buying it right here okay well
you're buying it awfully close to the
the the low of the day I mean the daily
price limit and if you do
that you know maybe you're looking for a
big move up but if you're doing that and
you know if you're buying it in here
around 7190 thinking oh you know I got
some nice supportive buying or whatever
who cares what the reason is the point
is if you got to turn and get out of
this thing and you're just right here at
limit down and you're like ah you know
what I'm wrong um you might not be able
to get
out okay at least today maybe you know
the next day when Market opens up you
know 2% lower you could get out or
something but just bear that in your
mind right if you're trading one of
those commodity markets that do have a
daily price limit and if you're trading
dangerously close to the Daily price
limit it's probably you know there's a
reason why the market is down almost 5%
right do you want to be a hero and try
to buy it off of down 5% no you know I
don't think that's a prudent trade to
take because if you're wrong your margin
for error to get out I don't want to say
it's small it's actually big because
you're not going to be able to get out
right because look imagine you buy it um
you know you're buying it down in here
oh look at the you know big buyers came
in here for whatever reason like I'm
going to get long and if you're wrong
and you got to get out and you try to
get out and someone just whack ta it
here limit down and and then it goes
limit
offered
boom next thing you know there's a
thousand in front of you trying to sell
also at limit down you're you're screwed
okay
so I hope that sort of clears up you
know again some of the misconception
of a limit move taking place in the
market right the market is still open
for trading until it closes for the day
cuz it could come off limit some
big buyer could come in and you know
China could come in and say oh you know
hey you know what we're going to buy it
for you know cuz it's Hogs you know we
need uh pork lift everything chances of
that is pretty small but um Market is
still open for trading until the close
of the day it'll just close down limit
down there's it's still open you could
buy all you want you just can't sell you
could try to sell you could join the
offer but chance of getting filled is
not going to happen all right
so again you know this is not something
a video that applies to everybody
because most people stick with the main
markets you know the the currencies the
equity indices um interest rates that
they're not in the grains or the meats
but if you are in the meats you know
just or you you're thinking about it
just be aware of that okay because that
is something that can happen and you
know I I seen Traders you years ago get
caught in limit moves that lasted for
several days against them I it's Margin
Call Margin Call Margin Call because
they can't get
out okay so you don't want to be in that
position anyway guys I'll end that video
here on that note um you know be sure to
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
you know this one didn't really talk a
lot about order flow but it sort of
talked about market conditions okay and
you know things that are important to
know about
markets so I'll catch you guys on the
next video take
care